Vice President Mike Pence also indicated
to us this morning that President Trump
will reveal his decision soon about the
Iran nuclear deal but he would not say
what it was the president told reporters
yesterday he has made up his mind
sources tell CBS News that the president
is in fact leaning toward certifying
that agreement the president may force
the issue by saying Iran is not
complying with the deal Iranian
president Hassan rouhani says the deal
is good and cannot be renegotiated Ian
Bremmer is the founder and president of
Eurasia group a global political risk
consulting company good morning Ian so
what are the stakes that the deal is not
recertified the stakes are if other
countries join us then the Iranians are
off to the races in terms of nuclear
capabilities and they'd be quite quick
about it but I think much more likely
would be that all of the others that are
involved in negotiations in the
settlement including our allies in
Europe France the UK would actually
stick with the deal and the Americans
would be effectively out in the cold and
I will tell you that this week the
Saudis the Israelis have been talking to
the Trump administration saying none of
us like this deal don't pull out and be
all by yourself so are there any
benefits to D certifying it if in fact
he is leaning toward that well the
benefit is that there is no pro Iran
Lobby in the United States and Congress
is not exactly happy with the Iranians
either so I think that at home
the average American would say Trump is
being tough on a country that clearly is
an enemy of our as they killd still call
us the Great Satan and the rest but yeah
you think this is simply negotiating
tactics or does he really plan to
decertify he personally wants out right
he doesn't like the deal he hated it
when Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
certified the last time around and if
you remember Trump already said that the
Iranians are not in compliance with the
spirit of the deal and he said frankly
they're probably not even in compliance
with the actual deal
so Trump himself personally doesn't feel
like he's certifying it and he's
instructed his national security advisor
and Secretary of State to find a way to
see if they can not recertify but not
formally pull out of the deal so
Congress would still kind of stick with
it and they're there working out what
they call the modalities of that right
now and I think that's the reason why
Trump is saying I've made up my mind but
I can't tell you it because they're
trying to find a way that they can still
say we're pushing we're pushing but
we're not blowing it up on North Korea
the Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
indicated last night that the sanctions
are starting to have an impact do you
see an indication of that I see an
indication that the entire world is
trying to find a way to show that they
are really upset with the North Koreans
continuing to escalate all aspects of
their nuclear cluding Russian program
including Russia and China now having an
effect in the sense that the Chinese are
now actually cracking down on smuggling
border controls I think that's a big
deal so you could say they're having an
effect on China working with the United
States that's a positive having an
effect on the North Koreans in terms of
in any way changing their orientation
towards showing the Trump doesn't have a
fist in his glove ultimately in stopping
their program no we haven't seen
anything like that yet among the member
states in the new United Nations what
was response to the President's speech
you know it's interesting it wasn't it
wasn't considered a horrible speech I
think most of it was seen as reasonably
statesmen like I mean this was Trump not
saying I don't care about the UN not
saying I'm gonna stop paying my
budgetary obligations right I mean
clearly it could have been a lot worse
and they're grading him on a curve right
there's no question it's in terms of
other things they expect from Trump not
from other presidents the Europeans
aren't happy they still have a real
problem with the fact that they don't
see Trump as aligned with values and the
fact that Trump came out and said at the
UN I'll completely destroy a country
that's not the kind of speech usually
here at the UN right but interestingly
in the Middle East the Israelis the
Palestinians the cutter ease some of the
other Gulf states have said that they
feel that Trump individually and
engaging with them really wants to get
to peace wants to facilitate a deal and
I wasn't hearing that from them frankly
a month ago so I mean I do think the
Trump is normalizing a little bit on the
foreign policy stage in part because the
national security people around him
particularly mattis and his chief of
staff are just having a lot more control
over who he sees who he doesn't see what
his notes are what kind of
Meishan he gets thanks Ramar always nice
to have you at the table
thank you sir